the UN calls the war in Yemen the
world's worst humanitarian crisis peace
talks aimed at ending the conflict are
showing small signs of progress more
than three years of fighting has killed
more than 10,000 people about 14 million
others are at risk of starvation
Elizabeth Palmer is the only u.s.
Network television correspondent in
Yemen she went to Aden to visit an
American group working to help children
there good morning the signs coming out
of the peace talks may be encouraging
but clearly this process is going to
take a very long time meanwhile Yemenis
have no choice but to struggle on the
most routine things like school are hard
one it's hard to believe now but three
years ago the abbas al husseiny school
was overrun by Houthi fighters they
turned it into a prison until they were
pushed out now the American aid
organization Mercy Corps has renovated
it over 600 students study here
including some who fled the fighting
further away like Riyadh do you know
anything about the peace talks that are
going on now between the Houthis and the
governments yes clearly not like most
teenage boys he's got more practical
things to worry about his studies for
example Riyadh told us he wants to be a
doctor the war has turned aid into a
lifeline in Yemen nearby Mercy Corps is
paying 70 men to install a solar-powered
water pump their salaries from this job
are all that stand between their
families the United Nations says that
three out of four Yemenis need aid right
now and yet millions aren't getting it
because of the fighting they're the ones
who are facing serious hunger this
winter for CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer
Aiden